this recipe is by sasuke loman and chris
kirindongo two curious our locals who
have immense appreciation for everything
from the island hi my name is chris rosa
and today i'm at the tasty kitchen to
make stuba so in a food processor you
would add cilantro your green bell
peppers red onions garlic and a little
bit of olive oil and you would process
this until the mixture is a little bit
chunky so after you're done with your
sofrito then you can make your stobah to
start with your stew you have to toss
your spirits in your sofrito until it's
fully coated and then leave it to
marinate for at least 20 minutes at room
temperature
plantains are very popular in the
caribbean so i'm creating a shredded
plantain bedding for our stew and as a
true kurosawan would say is
meaning it's a creole dish stemming
mostly from our african heritage as well
as other cultural influences that makes
curacao one of the most multicultural
hubs in the caribbean this recipe is
also a staple on the islands of aruba
and bonaire we will later serve this too
in a coconut which is a very popular
group in the caribbean if you're using
cured pork tail as i am right now you
would have to simmer it for 15 to 20
minutes to get rid of some of the salt
but if you're using uncured pork tail
you may need to actually add salt to the
recipe and at this point we're adding
some coconut oil garlic and onions to
our pot and cook them until they're a
little bit brown and fragrant then you
can add your pork tail water your
marinated spare ribs as well as a little
bit of salt and you can cook this for 90
minutes until your meat is tender the
water will evaporate so if you need to
just add a little bit more water after
90 minutes you add your green papaya
your ripe papaya some mango to
substitute sugar and sweet potato your
spices and some coconut water and then
you stew it for another 45 minutes you
know your stew is ready if your papaya
is cooked all the way through cause it's
a papayas too right papaya is a very
sweet fruit but the sweetness is
complemented by the saltiness of the
pork tail that will make all your taste
buds just harmonize in celebration of an
amazing flavor for this recipe we're not
wasting anything so i'm also baking off
my papaya seeds and use them as a
garnish for my stew to maximize the
island effect we're serving our stew in
a coconut with our baked plantain wrap
you know my grandma in curacao has no
idea what tasty or the internet is but
this is as delicious as the papaya
stobada my grandma used to make me as a
kid so grandma if you ever see this i
love you
oh yes
[Music]
you